holly williams is in the city of kharkiv
which is about 20 miles from the border
of russia holly good morning what was
your experience last night
good morning well it was just after 5
a.m local time that we started hearing a
series of loud thuds a dozen perhaps two
dozen of them clearly large explosions
they've continued sporadically by the
way shortly after that ukraine confirmed
it was under attack saying that they
were russian missile strikes targeting
its military infrastructure ukraine now
says that russian forces have come
across its borders including just near
here in kharkiv however we have not seen
them in the city at this point ukraine
says that it will distribute weapons to
veterans and volunteers so that they can
continue the fight and in that speech
last night uh president vladimir
zelinski got at that saying quote you
are courageous you are unbroken you are
ukrainian
how much warning did you get
yeah it was just minutes between
president putin appearing on russian
state tv saying that the operation had
started and the missile strikes landing
around har kiev now president putin said
quote russia's plans do not include
occupation but given that for weeks and
months russia said it had no plans to
invade ukraine we don't know really how
much trust can be placed in that
statement ukraine for its part is saying
that this is a full-scale invasion
and there are grave fears that this
could end up being the biggest land war
in europe since world war ii
holly williams and kharkiv thank you